um okay and this is what you're gonna
you're gonna see okay you go into these
modern churches you're gonna see the
young men under 40 or slowly leaving the
majority of the men are art are young
and naive and they don't know any better
or they're older and married but you
start to see the young men drop out of
churches
and you see just like on stage it's
mostly Whip and then it starts to be
more Comfort it starts to be
more entertaining you start to see
emotional men and women adapt to the
culture put on a house of God shows like
this this is craziness guys and then
you'll see the women's groups come in
where they everyone Comforts each other
because they don't typically demonize
female sin